okay first of all tyler scaled an icy
sixth studio album and you said this
album is more colorful
and and positive than your previous work
so why do you feel that way
um maybe it's to compensate for me
wearing black all the time
i don't know i just i wanted to shake
things up your lighting is
way better than mine what are you doing
i got a guy i gotta work on my
lighting situation do you need a glam
light i mean i
do i i got some something going on but i
don't it's it's
not even coming close to what you got
going on so do you maybe after the
interview you can send me some notes on
the tech that you got going on because
that you look fantastic
thank you i have wind machines i have
all the all the diva stuff we need
i can get that shipped over to you tyler
no you look great you're in the studio
you're working um
it's dope so um you know positive
colorful yeah let me i'll answer your
question about the record i'm sorry i
got
distracted um yeah i uh i think that
i was i was working on some music and
you know obviously that's that's what i
do
uh and i i didn't feel like it was i
didn't feel like it was appropriate to
just hold up a mirror to the
circumstances that we're all
experiencing right now especially this
past
year i wanted to escape it a bit and
really lean into imagination and
you know the idea that if you're
confined to one simple small space
and you focus on one tiny little detail
in that space
that detail can actually come to life
and fly around your room
and take you on a journey and i think
that that's you know the power of music
and creativity and leaning into that
imagination i think that this record is
going to be
you know a little more colorful and
exciting in that way yeah
there are still themes though of like
anxiety and loneliness
boredom doubt you know has having huge
success
contributed to feeling those things
wow uh you know i i think that with each
with each question that i answer in my
life there's another question that comes
up that i
inevitably don't have the answer too and
i use i use
you know i i i have a one-year-old
daughter and
in a lot of ways leading up to you know
being a dad
i always had this question of what's the
point what is my motivation what is
what are my goals and in a sense not
that it's completely
answered that question but in a sense i
can kind of look at her
as an answer to that question of what my
motivation is what is what is
you know why am i doing what i'm doing
uh and
um and so that's been an amazing kind of
uh
i guess question to have answered but
along with that
uh a myriad of other questions come with
it like how do i
how do i be the best dad how do i how do
i
um lead by perfect example and
um and you know all these how do i
convince her that i think that she's
beautiful and i want her to
be whoever she wants and all these
things that are kind of scary about
being a parent so
yeah um i've always used music to to
kind of
move forward in in my seasons of life
um and and this this season is no
different that i've been still
using music yeah how has that blended
been for you like just balancing you
know family and work because i know that
you made this entire album at home
so even just finding boundaries and
structure like what was that like for
you
yeah i mean it's it's tough because as
much as i you know i'm in a studio in
the basement and it's all soundproof
and everything i don't know what it is
but there's only one sound that cuts
through
all these walls and it is her running
across the kitchen floor
and so if i'm down here and i'm grinding
and all of a sudden i just hear that
pitter patter run above me it's so tough
not to just
press pause and everything i'm doing and
go up there and
you know see how she's doing and
inevitably my wife will say
all right you got her for a second i
gotta go do this thing and all of a
sudden i'm i'm stuck
uh babysitting for the next hour so i
gotta i gotta like uh
i take advantage of working from home as
much as i can but also
you're right the boundary thing is is
kind of tough because i gotta stay
focused too
yeah i know for sure rosie's popping
okay because from what i understand
she's on shy away
yeah she's well she's on a few things
yeah she's uh
we have did she she was on set there
um she actually showed up in this the
music video for a level of concern
which was a song we released a little
bit ago so yeah i don't know i
i think a lot of artists and um
musicians they
they like to separate their personal
life from their career and i totally
respect that and i understand why you
would do that
for me it just it was always it always
felt a little unnatural to do that
because
my personal life and who i am behind the
music
is so um it's it's
it's so important to who i am when i'm
doing music and so
josh and i the other guy in my band
we've always been inclined to involve
our family
to involve the people who are alive so
yeah you know a lot of our music videos
and a lot of the things that we do
just kind of sprinkle them in there
whenever we can and
um i hope one day rosie will look back
on a music video that she's in
and not resent me for it i mean
hopefully that doesn't happen but
i yeah i like i like commemorating
you know where we are in our life um
with uh music videos and stuff and
that's why we involve our family
sometimes
yeah well rosie's a little rock star so
i want to know like is she going to get
credit royalties what are we doing here
i told my wife that i think uh dj khaled
made his like one-year-old son an
executive producer and stuff and i was
thinking maybe i could
you know find her a title and get you
know get her fast tracked into a career
here but
she's only a year old so i think i'm
going to just hold off for now and let
her decide
so besides josh who is the person in
your life that you trust the most to
like play new music like who is your
litmus test
that's a good question i i have i have
two brothers um
and a sister yeah and they've i mean
they've been there since the beginning i
mean they watched me teach myself how to
play piano they've watched me figure out
how to
record music they they've heard me in
the other room at my parents old house
screaming my head off into a microphone
and wondering if it you know is he okay
i mean so they've been there
they've been there every step of the way
and so my family i do
i always go out of my way to make sure
that they they hear
you know something new um and you know
sometimes you get the right reaction
sometimes you feel like you got to go
back in the lab and make it better but
yeah along with josh the other guy in
the band i
you know they are the first people to
hear new stuff yeah
so there's a track bounce man and you
talk about getting together with your
friends at this stage in your life so
how
does that look now versus five years ago
or ten years ago man i think that
i i try to keep i i like keeping the
circle tight i know that that sounds a
little cliche but it is
very important to do that um and
in as much as i i like to do that even
you know looking back
six years ago when i when i was got
married you know looking at
the um you know the wedding and who was
invited there
it's a different group of people than
who i may have invited to that wedding
if it were
now and though so inevitably you're
going to see people coming in
and out of your life and that's very
natural and um
it can be sad sometimes but i do think
that the
you start to realize when those people
start to cycle in and out
yeah is when you start to truly
recognize the people who
are going to stay forever um and and
when you realize who those people are
you get to lean into them even more
and for me it truly is family uh and
it's not always the case for everyone
sometimes people have
um friends or um long time you know
friendships that that are just as
powerful and strong as family and
i think that as i get older i realize
which ones are mainstays
and so um yeah i mean it's you're gonna
have those people that come in and out
but
remember who's uh who's got your back
yeah
rosie's first birthday post on instagram
made me
just die it was so funny um how has
fatherhood just changed your priorities
when it comes to music and touring and
and all of that you know with the uh
with the pandemic and the lockdowns
obviously
a lot people have been working through a
lot and i and i
i never like to only look at a positive
of an overwhelmingly
you know tough and negative situation
but the truth is i was
able to stay home for the entirety of my
daughter's first year of life and to
really
look at that as a positive has been
something that um
yeah something that i've tried to i've
tried to you know come back to and
remember especially when i i start to
get
frustrated and um a little uh
a little down about that we're not out
playing shows like we usually are
so i that is one good thing and um at
some point i'm gonna have to show her
you know dad works you know i don't not
just i'm not just a bum
but so far all she knows is
dad's a bum what was your
wife's reaction to being on saturday
like was that a real phone call was that
a setup
yes no that was a real phone call
believe me she wanted to re-record it
she didn't like how she sounded like i'm
not re-recording anything this is it
you've got it like this is
so in the song saturday was i was
working on that song
and i was sitting in front of the
microphone working on some vocals
and it was coming towards the you know
the end of the evening and she called me
from upstairs
just to check in to see you know what's
my plan tonight and
you know it was just a very organic um
conversation
where she asked like are you working on
music i said yeah
and she says that's cool i'm gonna i'm
tired i'm gonna head to bed and i said
well no i want to watch friends with you
and that was
that was the show that we were like
watching at the time
yeah and um and then she said you know
listen if you've got the time and if
you're feeling inspired you should just
go for it and
i was recording that whole time while on
that phone call
and it just happened to fit perfectly as
the bridge
of the song and you know when she says
just go for it i you know i sing a high
note and we go into the last chorus and
i love it yeah i'm really um i'm really
proud of that one
that's awesome tyler thank you so much
for your time i really appreciate it
you're super dope
absolutely thanks for thanks for talking
you got it
bye tyler
you